[Musik]
ja
am tag meine damen und herren die
bundeskanzlerin der bayerische
ministerpräsident und der erste
hamburger bürgermeister wir nehmen jetzt
gerade über die gerade zu ende gegangene
video konferenz berichten
meine damen und herren wir hatten heute
wieder eine video schaltkonferenz mit
dem mit teilen der bundesregierung und
den ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder
das war uns seit juni praktisch die
nächste konferenz uns hat dazwischen lag
die sommerpause und ich darf sagen dass
wir seit mitte märz seitdem die cholera
ausgebrochen ist auch in deutschland
bund und länder immer die bekämpfung
dieser pandemie als eine gesamt
herausforderung verstanden haben das hat
sich bewährt trotz aller interessen und
regionalen unterschiede und deshalb darf
man alles in allem auch sagen dass wir
bislang gut durch diese pandemie
gekommen sind
dennoch sehen wir das in den letzten
wochen die infektionszahlen gestiegen
sind
es hat sich als besonders begünstigend
für die ausbreitung des virus wiesen
gemeinschafts unterbringungen
veranstaltungen feiern und
urlaubsbedingte mobilität und wir nehmen
diesen anstieg in diesen sommermonaten
sehr ernst und zwar insbesondere deshalb
weil wir jetzt ja eine sehr günstige
jahreszeit haben und hatten aber in den
nächsten monaten natürlich damit zu
rechnen ist dass sehr viel mehr
veranstaltungen im inneren stattfinden
müssen
und wir wissen alle dass niedrige
infektionszahlen die voraussetzung dafür
sind dass wir das infektionsgeschehen
unter kontrolle behalten dass unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
und damit auch die situation der
wirtschaft so ist dass die wirtschaft
arbeiten kann und die soziale lage in
deutschland sich möglichst positiv
entwickelt angesichts dieser gestiegenen
zahlen müssen wir jetzt also noch mal
einen neuen anlauf nehmen
viele sagen natürlich dass man sich
wünscht dass diese pandemie nicht mehr
da ist weiß dass das
anstrengend und belastend ist sich immer
wieder mit diesen fragen
auseinanderzusetzen
aber ich glaube es lohnt sich und
deshalb haben wir uns dieser
herausforderung heute auch gestellt wir
wollen unser gesundheitssystem in der
pandemie stark halten weil das jedem
einzelnen nutzt aber eben auch der
wirtschaft und auch dem öffentlichen
leben und sich deshalb haben wir uns mit
den verschiedenen aspekten auseinander
gesetzt wie wir das infektionsgeschehen
unter kontrolle halten können und
möglichst wieder zu niedrigeren zahlen
zurückkehren können von täglichen
infektionen dazu gehören die allgemeinen
regeln von rücksicht umsicht und
vorsicht das heißt wir haben erst einmal
festgestellt dass größere eröffnungs
schritte vorerst nicht zurecht fernsehen
sind als zusätzliche öffnung schritte
dabei bleiben natürlich immer auch die
möglichkeiten regionale anpassungen dass
es dabei bleibt den abstand einzuhalten
und wo notwendig wo das nicht möglich
ist den abstand einzuhalten und in
bestimmten öffentlichen bereichen mund
nasen bedeckung zu tragen
wir haben uns heute darauf verständigt
mit ausnahme eines bundeslandes sachsen
anhalt aber 15 bundesländer haben sich
darauf verständigt ein mindestbußgeld
von 50 euro festzulegen
und wir haben noch mal lange darüber
gesprochen über die erhebung solcher
bußgelder im regional und fernverkehr
und haben die verkehrsminister von bund
und ländern gebeten zu prüfen wie für
alle verkehrsträger im regional und
fernverkehr die voraussetzung dafür
geschaffen werden können das nicht ein
bußgeld sondern ein wie ein bußgeld
wirkendes erhöhtes beförderungsentgelt
eingeführt werden kann der unterschied
ist dass dies dann auch von den
beschäftigten in der bahn direkt erhoben
werden könnte
wir haben uns sehr ausführlich mit dem
test quarantäne und nach verfolgungs
regime für reiserückkehrer beschäftigt
es hat sich herausgestellt dass
zu wenig bekannt ist dass reisende aus
risikogebieten bereits seit monaten laut
verordnungen sich bei der rückkehr in
quarantäne zu begeben haben
und wir haben jetzt ja erlebt dass es
eine vielzahl von positiven testung weil
reiserückkehrern aus risikogebieten gab
deshalb ist da natürlich ein
zielgerichtetes test notwendig wir haben
auf der anderen seite gesehen dass die
reiserückkehrer die nicht aus
risikogebieten kommen mit einer ganz
ganz geringen zahl an infektionen
versehen sind und deshalb endet die
möglichkeit zur kostenlosen testung für
einreisende aus nicht risikogebieten am
september weil das nicht ein
zielgerichtetes testen ist wir haben uns
dann sehr intensiv mit reiserückkehrern
aus risikogebieten befasst und haben
festgelegt dass eben das weiter gilt was
auch heute schon gilt nämlich dass man
sich in quarantäne zu begeben hat das
wird da werden wir auch noch mal durch
geeignete informationen das mit sehr
viel stärker aufklären und bund und
länder ab der mit nachdruck an alle
reiserückkehrer die quarantäne pflichten
einzuhalten und damit ja auch ihrer
verantwortung gegenüber mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürgern gerecht zu werden
wir haben heute festgelegt und das ist
neu dass wir dazu aufrufen dass wo immer
das möglich ist auf reisen in
ausgewiesenen risikogebieten zu
verzichten ist und wir werden
kurzfristig eine rechtsänderung
anstreben mit dem ziel dass
bundeseinheitlich eine entschädigung für
den aus einkommensausfall dann nicht
gewährt wird wenn eine quarantäne
aufgrund einer vermeidbaren reise in
einem bei reiseantritt schon ausgewiesen
das risikogebiet angetreten wird
das sagen wir deshalb bei reiseantritt
schon ausgewiesen weil manche urlauber
jetzt hier erlebt haben das während
ihrer reise spanien zum beispiel zum
risikogebiet erklärt werden kann
das kann dann niemand dafür geradestehen
wer aber eine vermeidbare reise in einem
schon vorweisen
fest stehen das risikogebiet antritt da
wollen wir die rechtliche regelung zu
treffen dass es heute im
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht angelegt
aber da wollen wir die regierung zu
treffen dass dafür kein kompensation
mehr des verdienstausfalls möglich sein
wird wer gegen seine pflichten verstößt
im zusammenhang mit den quarantäne
notwendigkeiten für den werden
empfindliche also deutliche bußgelder
verhängt ein problem bei den
reiserückkehrern de sind die aussteiger
karten die oft nicht vollständig
ausgefüllt sind und deshalb wird es hier
eine digitalisierung der elektronischen
reiseanmeldung geben
der bund arbeitet mit hochdruck daran
vorrangig das bundesinnenministerium das
soll dann auch eine schnelle
übermittlung an die öffentliche
gesundheitsämter vor ort möglich machen
und die müssen dann natürlich den dingen
nachgehen das ist eine große zusätzliche
aufgabe und deshalb muss auch das reisen
in risikogebiete eingeschränkt werden
wir haben ja wie sie wissen vor einigen
wochen die testpflicht für rückkehrer
aus risikogebieten eingeführt es hat
hier ein großer anstrengungen gegeben
und es hat sich gezeigt dass an den test
stationen sowohl an den flughäfen aber
auch an den autobahnen ein großer teil
doch also ein überproportionaler teil
von zurückkehrenden positiv getestet
wurde und das zeigt dass hier doch eine
besondere vorsicht geboten ist zum teil
2 prozent wird uns gesagt von
einreisenden waren positiv infiziert und
deshalb
werden wir diesen dieses vorgehen auch
aufrecht erhalten jetzt in den nächsten
wochen aber das ganze hat den nachteil
dass die ansteckung in den letzten tagen
des urlaubs von diesen tests natürlich
nicht erfasst werden wer sich drei oder
vier tage vor seiner rückreise nach
deutschland angesteckt hat der kann
durch einen solchen test nicht erfasst
werden das heißt wenn wir die digitalen
einreise karten haben wenn wir besser
die quarantäne überwachen können dann
werden auch rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten sich ab erst im oktober
oder etwa am ersten oktober dann
möglichst ab erster oktober haben wir
geschrieben werden die dann diese
reisenden auffordern sich in selbst die
situation also quarantäne zu begeben und
diese quarantäne von 14 tagen kann nur
aufgelöst werden wenn ab dem fünften tag
einen test gemacht wird der dann negativ
ist also für den nächsten monat
september bleibt alles wie es ist wir
arbeiten daran dass quarantäne besser
durchgesetzt werden kann und dass die
einreise karten digitalisiert werden und
dann werden wir zu einem modifizierten
regime übergehen bei dem dann der test
ab dem fünften tag durchgeführt wird
wir werden unsere möglichst breite test
kapazitäten bemühen denn wir haben ja
nicht nur reisende zu testen sondern das
test regime das die tests strategie
konzentriert sich natürlich auch
symptomatische verdachtsfälle dann aber
eben auch auf altenheime auf menschen
mit behinderung pflegeheime
krankenhäuser und hinzu kommt wegen der
hohen priorität auch die konzentration
auf schulen auf lehrer auf kitas wir
wollen das robert koch institut noch
einmal bitten dass man die dauer der
quarantäne sich noch einmal anschaut ob
ihr verkürzungen möglich sind das muss
aber natürlich fachlich gewährleistet
sein
und wir haben darüber gesprochen dass
wir am 8 september eine große konferenz
durchführen werden mit
bereichen des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes der bund gibt vier
milliarden zur verstärkung der arbeit
des gesundheitsdienstes lassen sie mich
auch danken den ganzen mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern die jetzt wirklich viel
zu tun hatten auch in den sommermonaten
wir können ja auch nicht sagen dass das
wirklich besser wird zum schulbetrieb
könnte sagen dass sehr viel gearbeitet
wurde um präsenzunterricht möglich zu
machen
wir wollen und so haben wir es auch
festgelegt dass die für die breite
akzeptanz der hygienevorschriften im
schulbetrieb sicherstellen dass diese
bundesweit nach in der
kultusministerkonferenz vereinbarten
vergleichbaren maßstäben erfolgen die
hygiene konzepte in den schulen da ist
schon viel erreicht und daran wird auch
weiter gearbeitet und wir haben nochmal
darüber informiert dass wir jetzt
zusätzlich fünf tage pro kind den eltern
jedem elternteil weiter diesen in diesem
jahr freistellung ermöglichen von der
arbeit entgeltliche also entgelt
bezahlte freistellung weil wir doch
sehen dass die unsicherheit wenn jemand
wenn ein kind schnupfen hat wenn
getestet werden muss für die eltern ganz
außerordentlich ist ausbau der digitalen
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten das hatten
wir im koalitionsausschuss beschlossen
wir haben dann die vereinbarung von juni
das keine großveranstaltungen
stattfinden können bei denen eine
kontakt verfolgung und die einhaltung
von hygieneregeln nicht möglich ist dass
diese dieses nicht stattfinden wurde
jetzt von ende oktober noch einmal
verlängert bis ende dezember
es wird eine arbeitsgruppe der länder
auf der innen herrschaften staatskasse
eingeben die sich dann auch mit sport
bundesweiten sportveranstaltungen bis
ende oktober beschäftigt um dann
vorschläge zu machen die man das tun
kann
wir weisen noch mal hin weil der zweite
große bereich in denen sehr viele
infektionen auftreten die privaten
familie
feiern im freundeskreis sind dass hier
große achtsamkeit zu leisten ist dass
man sich schauen muss in welchem umfang
das notwendig ist und dass vor allen
dingen in geschlossenen räumen auf eine
wirkliche gute durchlüftung zu sorgen
ist wir haben dann die maßnahmen des
koalitionsausschusses zur stützung der
wirtschaft noch einmal hier erwähnt
alles in allem also eine breite palette
die sich ausrichtet auf unseren neuen
erkenntnisse aus dem sommer es ist viel
urlaub viel mobilität vieles möglich
gewesen aber wir sehen auch wo wir
wachsam sein müssen und das sind eben
die risikogebiete
das sind die privaten feiern und deshalb
an dieser stelle ein besonderer fokus
auf unserer beschlussfassung ich bedanke
mich bei allen die mitgewirkt haben das
waren ja mehr als hier am tisch sitzen
frau bundeskanzlerin
das war eine sehr intensive diskussion
heute da gab es auch einige unterschiede
es gab unterschiedliche auffassungen
ende bin ich doch sehr dankbar und froh
dass wir an einen pfad haben den wir
weiter gemeinsam beschreiben denn man
darf corona nicht unterschätzen auch
wenn sie regional unterschiedliche
infektionszahlen gibt corona ist wieder
voll da in deutschland deswegen müssen
wir uns dieser herausforderung stellen
im grunde genommen ist das problem wir
haben ja alle vor der situation des
urlaubs gewarnt oder sagen gehabt
bestätigt sich dass der urlaub ein
risiko ist und war und dass insbesondere
viele familien heimkehrer davon
besonders betroffen weil sie die
steigenden infektionszahlen bayern kann
ich das sagen aber ich würde es auch von
anderen kollegen in anderen ländern
hängen sehr stark mit diesem phänomen
zusammen urlaub und familien heimkehrer
und dem wachsenden leichtsinn und der
unvernunft durch verschiedene partys so
das problem ist es ist zu früh zu hoch
bezahlt
sie sieht vor die tatsache dass wir vor
dem winter stehen der nicht kalkulierbar
es jedenfalls aus jetziger sicht bei dem
wir nicht wissen wie wirkt sich dann
grippe und andere erkrankungen aus sind
die zahlen zu früh zu hoch
also muss unser ziel sein die zahlen
wieder runter zu bringen
auf der einen seite und gleichzeitig
keinen zweiten lockdown zu haben das
heißt gezielt zu reagieren
keinen generellen zweiten lok thomson wo
zu gewährleisten dass wirtschaft aber
vor einer schule und kita funktioniert
das sind sozusagen die oberbegriffe mit
denen wir uns beschäftigt haben daraus
folgt dann auch die konsequenz der
entscheidung in alle details nämlich
nicht zuzuschauen sondern weichen zu
stellen nicht die zeit für weitere
grundlegende öffnungen lockerung und
umgekehrt regional angepasst auch zu
reagieren
das was glaube ich vor allem auch steht
ist dort wo die infektionszahlen wachsen
und zwar schnell wachsen muss man
schneller reagieren
je höher sie sind desto mehr muss
passieren wo die konsequente es ist
letztlich das instrumentarium bei den
glaube ich auch jeder mitgehen kann
so unterschiedlich er auch in seinem
land die jeweilige situation sieht darum
ist es erstens positiv bei der
konsequenten anwendung das sind mal
gelungen ist bis auf sachsen anhalt bei
der maske eine untergrenze für das
bußgeld zu machen das heißt alle die
mehr angehalten ist aber immerhin mal
eine untergrenze und die vereinbarung
dass bei den überregionalen
verkehrsachsen also bei der bahn auch
umzusetzen
dies ist sehr wichtig denn die maske ist
das einzige was wir im grunde genommen
haben wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind derzeit
corona irgendwann davon zu bekämpfen es
gibt nach wie vor keinen impfstoff
einige erfolge bei medikamenten aber im
wesentlichen geht es darum das argument
dass es bislang nicht in die
krankenhäuser umschlägt ist sein
das erfüllt uns mit hoffnung aber ist
wohl auch der tatsache geschuldet dass
vor allem sehr viele junge menschen
betroffen sind
und es ist nur eine frage der zeit ist
bis sich das wieder ein anderer bereiche
auswirken kann
klar ist masten pflicht haben wir heute
nicht intensiver besprochen aber klar
ist je höher die infektionen sind desto
eher muss man sie ausweiten übrigens ist
das immer noch das mildeste mittel mit
abstand das mildeste mittel im vergleich
zur lockt als wir uns bei den
veranstaltungen heute lang unterhalten
ich glaube das ist auch ein guter
kompromiss
bis 31.12 großveranstaltungen nicht
erlaubnis nur wenn etwas geht das ist
regional wird das unterschiedlich
gesehen
neben hygienemaßnahmen schlicht und
einfach vom infektionsgeschehen ab wenn
infektionsgeschehen wächst ist es nicht
sehr vertretbar eine form von weiteren
veranstaltungen zuzulassen
deswegen ist es auch beim fußball nicht
sinnvoll jetzt im september mit
zuschauern zu starten die liga hat ein
wirklich gutes hygiene konzept gemacht
und persönlich bin überzeugt dass einige
sehr große vereine da vieles umsetzen
können aber es ist in einer steigenden
infektionszahlen ein falsches signal
weil der fußball auch eine auswirkung
auf kultur und andere veranstaltungen
wir jetzt sagen würden wir geben alles
frei deswegen eben bis zum die
bundeskanzler sagte bis 31.10
eine arbeitsgruppe die sich damit
beschäftigt wie unter welchen umständen
an danach die perspektive möglich ist
aber ganz klar
jetzt passt es in dem mystischen der
schule kita und der wirtschaftsbetrieb
läuft dann erst das ist die priorität
kommen andere bereiche dazu was uns
wirklich große sorge macht ist neben dem
thema urlaub und familien heimkehren
da besteht immer die hoffnung dass nach
dem ende der ferien auch dadurch dass
man für tests hat auch viel erkennt dass
wieder etwas nach und entwickeln kann
ist aber das thema nochmal partys
insgesamt damit sehr viele kommunen die
regieren wie ich finde sehr gut sind
bayern und die stadt münchen hat für
bestimmte party bereiche ein nächtliches
alkoholverbot gemacht das glaube ich
sehr hilft was schmerzhaft ist weil es
eigentlich nicht unser liberalen
lebensphilosophien spricht aber kann
helfen
da glaube ich wir geben die kommunen
schon sehr gut und vorbildlich
wir haben somit dem thema familienfeiern
und auch privat feiern
beschäftigt man es da keine
abschließende regelung für alle
getroffen
aber alle sind sich bewusst dass das ein
thema und das deswegen unbedingt darauf
geachtet werden muss in den jeweiligen
regionen darauf hinzuweisen im
appellativen charakter aber auch so
werden aus zu überlegen beispielsweise
das dann auch aufgezeichnet wird wer ist
da um eine nachverfolgung zu machen
letzter punkt aus meiner sicht mit den
tests
da hatten wir die letzten tage jetzt
würde ich immer sagen eine relativ große
bandbreite an überzeugungen
richtige weg ist auch so für nicht gut
dass man sich noch mal auf eine
einheitliche strategie verständigt haben
weil weil ja auch für die menschen große
unsicherheit ist aus meiner überzeugung
nach war die bisherige test strategie
richtig darf das ausdrücklich sagen aber
mit der festlegung auf die
verpflichtenden tests ich kann es nur
für den freistaat bayern sagen
trotz einiger einiger pannen wenn man
sieht wie viele positive tests gefunden
wurde
jeden tag mit einer erhöhten positiv
gerade gegenüber dem normalen
testverfahren an den gesundheitsämtern
oder bei den ärzten zeigt sich dass der
eben eine sehr hohe zahl an infektionen
geist und wahrscheinlich die
dunkelziffer noch höher ist denn an den
flughäfen war es ja klar dass die
verpflichtung gut kontrollierbar ist
schwieriger ist es beim auto von karten
länder die heute relativ hohe
infektionsrate haben uns da auch ein
stück weit wie alle betroffenen sind da
ist der überwiegende teil der menschen
kommt mit dem auto zurück es sind glaube
ich war das war das richtig und wir
halten daran fest wir haben einige
regelung getroffen aber erst den oktober
soll es in einer anderen form sein wobei
ich das für sind freistaat bayern sagen
kann wir halten auch auf jeden fall bis
dahin an allen fest was wir machen auch
mit den kostenlosen tests mehr wir
glauben dass das ein wichtiges
serviceangebote staates ist auch
kostenlose tests für die bürger zu
machen aus risikogebieten aber eben auch
aus nicht- risikogebieten was wichtig
ist die umstellung ab dem ersten oktober
die hat auch hamburg sehr stark und auch
und schon überzeugenden argumenten wenn
ich das so sagen darf wirklich auch
dahin gestellt noch mal es hängt sehr
davon ab ob es uns gelingt folgendes zu
erreichen
das quarantäne durchgesetzt wird und die
aussteiger karten digitalisiert sind des
bundesinnenministeriums
bundesgesundheitsministerium heute noch
mal gesagt dass sie daran arbeiten wir
hoffen sehr dass es dann bis ende
september alles klappt bisherige
erfahrung mit digitalen umsteiger
konzepten lassen zumindest lassen
zumindest erahnen dass das eine
ehrgeizige sache werden wird
denn bislang ist das mit den aussteiger
karten kein erfolgsmodell muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen wird schlecht
geschrieben falsche nummern ähnliches
mehr
und die durchsetzung der quarantäne die
die kommunen ja machen müssten und bzw
auch die länder ist mit bisherigen
personal zumindest nicht einfach zu
machen wir sie müssen nur aufpassen dass
man am schluss keine test samt und
trotzdem keiner in quarantäne geht und
das ganz eingebaut sind
das wären wir wohl eher glaube ist der
heutige schritten wichtiger part wo es
mehr klarheit und sicherheit gibt und
der hinweis in risikogebiete nicht zu
reisen und dann auch entsprechende
konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen wenn man
nicht geschäftlich muss oder es gibt
eine eine ganz private sache im sinne
von familien betroffenheiten
beispielsweise tod eines
familienangehörigen ist etwas anderes
ist schon mal ein wichtiges signal bei 1
hat mich alex hat schon sehr überrascht
ich meine jetzt nicht bei den relativ
spontanen ausweisung von risikogebieten
bei spanien weise einen relativ
überraschend also über nacht kam das ja
das ziel aber ehrlich gesagt schon ganz
schön überrascht hat hat auch ziemlich
viel probleme ausgelöst aber war
verständlich wir müssen schon schauen
dass mich dann wenn eventuell lange
angekündigt wird etwas ist ein
risikogebiet und leute fahren in urlaub
hin
dann ist ein stückweit eigene
verantwortung auch da eigene
verantwortung heißt nämlich nicht wenn
der staat seine verantwortung der bürger
zurück gibt dass es kein problem geben
sondern muss auch erfüllen
trotzdem ist es unsere kernaufgabe die
vernünftigen vor den unvernünftigen zu
schützen
mit den jetzigen instrumentarium das wir
haben glaube ich ist das gut lösbar
deswegen noch mal danke aber eines ist
klar wir werden in den ländern
das ist ja heute schon bei dem einen
thema angekündigt worden
noch unterschiedliche akzente haben das
hat mit infektionsgeschehen zusammen
aber was trotzdem wichtig ist der geist
heute wieder die gemeinsame philosophie
die war spürbar die spiegelt sich auch
in einem sehr ausführlichen text wieder
da noch mal herzlichen dank für die
zusammenarbeit bundeskanzlerin sehr
geehrte damen und herren das war heute
eine sehr wichtige beratung dass wir
nach vielen wochen über die sommerzeit
jetzt noch einmal eine einheitliche
sicht hergestellt haben
auf die korona lage in deutschland die
sind uns alle sehr einig dass jetzt mal
noch in einer stabilen lage sind aber
dass wir sehr schwierige monate vor uns
haben auf die wir uns möglichst gut und
einheitlich auch vorbereiten müssen
deswegen ist es gelungen heute zu sagen
wir brauchen ein einheitliches
mindestbußgeld in deutschland wir
brauchen einheitliche maßstäbe für das
vorgehen in schulen wir haben eine
gemeinsame sicht auf die problematik der
privaten feiern entwickelt und wir
wissen dass wir auch im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr möglichst einheitlich
in deutschland auf die einhaltung der
masken pflicht achten werden
ich bin sehr froh dass das auch gelungen
ist über die test strategie im hinblick
auf reiserückkehrer wirklich eine
einheitliche sicht herzustellen denn wir
wissen alle
jede erkannte früh erkannte infektion
ist ein gewinn
jede nicht erkannte infektion ist ein
problem und jede nicht infizierte person
wie die infizierte person die ein
negatives testergebnis bekommt ist
richtig gehen eine gefahr denn das sind
personen die dann mit trügerischer
sicherheit problematische
infektionsketten auslösen können und
deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass wir uns
vereinbart haben ist zum möglichst
anfang oktober
es kommt man ja die neue reisezeit die
herbstferien dass wir eine neue
rationale test strategie entwickeln und
umsetzen bei der es sehr darauf ankommt
dass einige tage quarantäne eingehalten
werden um dann mit sicherheit
auszuschließen dass eine infektion
stattgefunden hat oder eben auch eine
infektion zu bestätigen die dann zu
einer längeren quarantäne führen wird
insofern eine sehr wichtige beratung
sehr gute ergebnisse ist es uns gelungen
an vielen punkten einheitliche
sichtweisen oder einheitliche regelungen
herzustellen
deswegen freue ich mich sehr und ich
glaube es war wichtig dass wir das heute
hinbekommen haben dann sind wir bei
ihren fragen die erste kommt von herrn
brandt von dpa frau bundeskanzlerin sie
wollten bei der sitzung heute ein signal
der einheitlichen maßstäbe setzen nun
haben sie gerade bei familienfeiern die
durchaus problematisch sein können und
festen keine konkreten zahlen
durchsetzen können ist das ein großes
problem wäre es nicht gerade da wichtig
gewesen dass durchzusetzen und herr
ministerpräsident söder
die arbeitsgruppe zum fußball und
anderen sportarten mit zuschauern bis
ende oktober ein ergebnis rechnen sie
damit dass noch in diesem jahr
spiele wo auch immer mit mehreren
tausend zuschauern möglich sind noch in
diesem jahr
also ich glaube das ist wichtig war dass
er erstmal den fokus familienfeiern noch
einmal gesetzt haben dass da eine
sensibilität da ist ich glaube auch dass
wir uns in den nächsten wochen damit
weiter werden beschäftigen müssen wenn
man nicht mehr so viel rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten haben kann es sein dass
hier gerade in dem familiären umfeld
doch auch gefahren lauern dass von dort
sehr viele infektionen ausgehen und
deshalb haben wir uns heute nur auf
diese einheitliche maßstäbe einigen
können weil die länder sehr
unterschiedliche vorstellungen haben die
man am heutigen tag nicht zusammen
bringen konnte ich denke aber auch dass
wir an dem thema weiter dran bleiben
werden in den wintermonaten jetzt ist ja
vieles im freien das ist nicht so
dramatisch aber ich glaube wenn es sich
dann mehr in sehr enge wohnräume
verlagert dann kann es sein dass man
darauf zurück kommt ich wünsche es mir
natürlich nicht aber es ist heute mit
den geltenden regeln die sind zu weit
aufgefächert als dass man das zusammen
bringen konnte bei fußball nehmen beim
fußball insbesondere weil es ja draußen
ist da gibt's schon eine perspektive das
allerdings nicht so wie man sich
vorstellen wieder die stadien alle voll
werden aber da kann es schon möglichkeit
geben das eine eine kleine ein
schrittweise möglichkeit dann vereinbart
werden kann
das könnte noch vor weihnachten der fall
sein aber das hängt alles davon ab wie
das infektionsgeschehen ist das gilt für
viele dinge wir haben uns heute den
explizit über karneval gesprochen oder
weihnachtsmärkte zum beispiel es gibt
eine einzige stelle insgesamt köln die
sagen weihnachtsmärkte ab so weit sind
wir haben uns heute auch auf keinen fall
verständigt weil wir auch sagen das
hängt auch von den konzepten ab die vor
ort gemacht werden
da gibt es ja auch verschiedene ideen
die man so dass dann abfahren kann und
hängt dann auch vom lokalen
infektionsgeschehen ab also ein sehr
gutes hygiene konzept bei sehr niedrigen
infektionszahlen in einem land klar ist
da gibt es ja einige erleichterndes im
moment ist aber halt gerade in den
großstädten der wechsel am stärksten so
fern
19 da sich weiterentwickelt habe ich mal
stück aufsicht auch vielleicht zwar
fällt nur eine ergänzung habe lang wir
haben bei denen familienfeiern noch
gesagt in abhängigkeit vom regionalen
infektionsgeschehen können dann auch für
private feiern oder sind für private
feiern beschränkungen zu erlassen das
haben alle auch so gesehen und zum
beispiel durch die absenkung der höchste
teilnehmerzahl also das ist schon
gemeinsamkeit dass wenn das
infektionsgeschehen explodiert in
regional dass man dann genau auch bei
dieser besucherzahl teilnehmerzahl
ansetzen muss
delfs bloomberg ja eine frage an die
frau bundeskanzlerin sie hatten ja
kürzlich nach dem treffen mit dem
französischen präsidenten gesagt das ist
auch ihr ziel wäre auf der europäischen
ebene so eine einheitliche regelung und
maßnahmen hinzukriegen
jetzt nach der heutigen erfahrung mit
den mit auf bundesebene sind sie der
optimistischer der pessimistischer
geworden dass sie so eine einheitliche
regelung in europa hinkriegen
heute war es ja offenbar nicht so
einfach und dann noch eine frage
entweder sie haben ja jetzt immer wieder
die kanzlerin hier beobachten können bei
den verhandlungen und vielleicht auch
mitgekriegt dass es manchmal gar nicht
so einfach ist alle unter einen hut zu
kriegen wenn sie sie so beobachten
kriegen sie da eigentlich mehr lust auf
diesen job in berlin
oder würden sie sagen um gottes willen
nicht bleibt lieber in bayern
naja ich hab nicht weil ich ja bezogen
auf auch unsere incident wie man so
schön sagt 50 infizierte pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen
und da kann man schon sagen das hast
europäische jetzt eigentlich dazu
geführt dass sehr viele länder das
vernehmen und genau diese gebiete dann
auch als risikogebiete bei sich selbst
ausweisen oder wir tun das dann wie wir
es jetzt auch leider im blick auf paris
oder brüssel tun mussten und das ist
eigentlich eine weitgehend akzeptierte
vorgehensweise und ich erinnere mich
noch wir haben wir da sehr intensiv
damals darüber diskutiert ob wir das
machen sollen und es ist von vielen
ländern auch für sich als akzeptabel
aktien angenommen worden wir haben für
den nicht außer europäischen
reiseverkehr
auch das 20 infizierte pro sieben tage
und 100000 wenn wir länder rausnehmen
wollen aus den risikogebieten
da sind wir also noch ein bisschen
strenger als mit uns selbst aber im
schengen raum sind diese 50 pro 100000
eigentlich sehr gut akzeptiert und ich
will deutlich sagen ich hatte ja
natürlich auch das gespräch mit fresken
und sieben kultusministern wir werden
das ja auch mit allen kultusminister
noch einmal fortsetzen
und was ich dort gesehen habe das ist
die sehr große bereitschaft auch eine
einheitliche geschichte erzählen zu
können über das vorgehen immer in
abhängigkeit vom infektionsgeschehen so
wie es markus söder auch gesagt hat und
insofern waren die beratungen heute
nicht schwieriger als die in anderen
fällen waren wir waren da eigentlich ich
meine wir haben immer bestimmte probleme
das ist ja gar keine frage weil wir eben
auch die niedrigste instanz eines
bundeslandes ist glaube ich 12 und die
höchste ist 19 im augenblick für das
gemittelt auf das ganze bundesland das
heißt wir haben schon sehr sehr
unterschiedliche gegebenheiten auch aber
der wille hier auch gerade bei
reiserückkehrern aus risikogebieten
gemeinsam zu handeln
auch qualitative veränderungen
durchzuführen dass man die fan szene
eben rechtliche regelung finden wir die
quarantäne nicht mehr zu bezahlen durch
entgeltfortzahlung oder kompensation des
verdienstausfalls und auch die
bereitschaft ein mindestbußgeld
einzuführen das sehe ich schon beim
nicht einheiten dessen und nasenschutz
so sehe ich schon als etwas an was für
vortagen monaten vielleicht noch nicht
so hinbekommen hätten zu der wichtigen
frage von ihnen noch also nächste mal
habe ich schon immer und immer mehr in
dem letzten monate geduld der
bundeskanzlerin bewundert und zwar nicht
nur bei minister sind konferenzen im
koalitionsausschuss sitzungen haben
mindestens die gleiche sind die gleiche
herausforderung an geduld und
durchhaltefähigkeit insofern
verwunderlich jede geduld anderen
gegenüber auch mir gegenüber immer
wieder
insofern das ist aber ein status den
glaube ich keiner erreichen kann
allerdings hilft ihm als vorbild egal wo
man seinen platz hat der wie sie zu
überraschen wird bei mir in bayern ist
herr reuters ich hätte eine frage die
beiden ministerpräsidenten
sie haben jetzt ein einheitliches
bußgeld mindestschwelle vereinbart aber
haben sie sich auch gegenseitig
verpflichtet dass sie das umsetzen und
anwenden denn das war ja eines der
probleme auch von anderen regeln in den
letzten wochen gewesen also gibt es
jetzt diese gemeinsame verpflichtungen
und frau bundeskanzlerin weil wir im
moment im fast täglichen rhythmus
verlängerung beschließen beim
koalitionsausschuss jetzt auch wieder
verlängerung was ist eigentlich ihre
haltung zu der verlängerung des
mehrwertsteuersatzes können wir den in
den nächsten tagen oder wochen auch
erwarten
ja also wir haben nicht nur vor dieses
bußgeld zu beschließen und wir werden
das einführen und dann auch vollziehen
natürlich immer da wo es nötig ist der
unterschiedliche bereiche und
unterschiedliche diszipliniert hat in
deutschland wir haben jetzt gerade ein
quasi bußgeld im öffentlichen nahverkehr
bereits eingeführt wenn denn das
erhöhtes beförderungsentgelt aber jetzt
kommen wir mit diesem hoheitlichen
bußgeld natürlich auch ein stück härter
daher und ich glaube das zeigt dass wir
in deutschland ist sehr ernst nehmen und
alle nicht alle 16 aber alle 15 länder
die diesen beschluss heute mitgetragen
haben werden das ist nicht einführen und
dann auch vollziehen stützen so die
allgemeine mehrwertsteuersenkung endet
am 31 12 2020 und ab dann können sich
die bürgerinnen und bürger auf die
senkung des soli freuen uns jedenfalls
für über 90 prozent der bürgerinnen und
bürger und weitere leistungen die dann
in kraft treten zum beispiel erhöhtes
kindergeld und ähnliches so dass ich
glaube dass wir da auch noch mal eine
interessante und auch konjunkturell
positive anschlussregelung haben also
eine letzte frage hätte ich noch gesehen
oder also frau aigner auf jedem vierten
der deutschen welle noch und dann
vielleicht noch sehen wenn ich schluss
der frau bundeskanzlerin der
vergangenheit hat die bundesregierung
haben ja auch die länder vor allem auf
die eigenverantwortung der bürger gesetz
das es bedeutet ja jetzt eine zäsur wenn
sie da so aufrufen nicht in diese
risikogebiete zu reisen wie nah ist
deutschland denn im augenblick daran zu
überlegen reise verbote auszusprechen
grenzen wieder zu schließen und noch
stärker auf kontrolle statt auf
eigenverantwortung zu setzen und herrn
herrn söder vielleicht die frage dass
sie uns ein bisschen über den verlauf
der gespräche berichten können wir
wollen keine grenzkontrollen wieder
einführen die lage ist auch so dass
wir viel regionaler reagieren wollen das
ist ja unsere ganze absicht dass wir
nicht wieder zur totalen
flächendeckenden schließungen kommen
wollen und wenn alle sich anstrengen
glaube ich ist das auch möglich und
deshalb sehe ich also solche solche
situation nicht wir können auch nicht
ganz so einfach reiseverbote aussprechen
das würde dann wirklich ganz kontrollen
voraussetzung das wollen wir nicht schon
gar nicht im schengen raum
aber wir müssen das ist ja auch ein
aufruf zur eigenverantwortung der
bürgerinnen und bürger eben einfach
sagen wenn es keine dringende reisen
keinen bringenden reisegrund gibt es
kann immer solche dringenden reisen
grunde geben viele menschen mit
türkischen wurzeln mit kosovarischen mit
bosnischen wurzeln können schwierige
familiensituationen haben das wollen wir
auch nicht gänzlich verbieten
aber das kann nicht der regelfall sein
und dass es heute glücklicherweise
gemeinsam vereinbart war
mit dem diskussionsverlauf weniger
dramatisch als in verschiedenen live
tickern war ich so sagen darf
und ansonsten also ich glaube es war
eine sehr konstruktive diskussion an der
einen stelle sind auch unterschiedliche
temperamente einzubringen aber es war
glaube ich insgesamt sehr gut wie immer
bei allen das ergebnis zählt und das
ergebnis ist sehr gut und sehr
konstruktiv die letzte frage von
frankreich bild meine frage an die zwei
fragen an die frau bundeskanzlerin bei
den privat veranstaltungen in den
schulen gibt es jetzt moment noch keine
einheitlichen lösungen können sie
vielleicht kurz beschreiben was denken
sie warum konnten sie sich heute nicht
durchsetzen und der berliner
innensenator hat ja die am wochenende
stattfindenden demonstrationen untersagt
was halten sie davon
also ich respektiere die berliner
entscheidung
wir haben ja auch gerichtliche
überprüfung wege in deutschland wir sind
ein rechtsstaat man wird sehen wie sich
das dann entwickelt aber dass bei denen
natürlich auch sehr viel wert darauf
legt dass auch demonstration wird jene
vorschriften unterliegen ist klar also
respekt dafür ich habe ansonsten diese
entscheidung nicht zu treffen das ist
eine berliner entscheidung gewesen und
zwar hätte natürlich noch mal sagen beim
spielbetrieb ist es nicht so wie es auch
schon berichtet wurde es wir haben ihm
aufgenommen für die breite akzeptanz der
hygienevorschriften im schulbetrieb ist
es wesentlich dass diese nach bundesweit
in der kultusministerkonferenz
vereinbarten vergleichbaren maßstäben
erfolgen
der gegenstand der diskussion war gibt
es nicht schon einheitliches vorgehen
und es war so geschrieben als würden wir
damit gerade erst beginnen aber das ist
ein bedürfnis nach bundesweit
einheitlichen vorgehen auch in
abhängigkeit vom infektionsgeschehen das
kann wieder auch regional
unterschiedlich sein gibt es wohl
überhaupt nicht in frage gestellt und
insofern bin ich mit dem ergebnis sehr
zufrieden
danke ich noch einen schönen tag